So this works for things other than words. The place where
you've seen it the most so far has been in language,
but we're also going to to see how to use it to
make procedures. And you'll also see how to use it in
later classes, how to define data structures. There are lots and
lots of different things in computing that are defined recursively. And
a recursive definition has two parts. It has the base case.
In our example with the word, that was the second rule.
And the base case we can think of as
a starting point. And the important thing about the base
case, is it's not defined in terms of itself. It
has to be something where we already know how to
define it. So for programs, it's usually going to be the
smallest input, or one of the simplest inputs. Something where
we already know the answer. We don't have to do
any computation to figure it out. The second part is
the recursive case. And that is defined in terms of itself.
[BLANK_AUDIO]
But it shouldn't be defined in terms of
itself exactly. It should be defined in terms of
some sort of smaller version of itself. We need
to make progress to eventually get to the base
case. We'll see what that means in programs
soon. First, we're going to try one other example not
in terms of a program, just to get a
better sense for how things can be defined recursively.